welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz and this
is another installment of 15 minutes
with a mentor series
and really excited to be joined by ben
duncan over in australia today and in
this series really simply we're going to
ask
some of the mentors from inside the
community seven
questions in 15 minutes i'm going to do
this every day
in conjunction with the launch of the
recruitment mentors community so
before we get into this ben if you could
introduce yourself for those that may
not know who you are
and uh we'll do this cool yeah thanks
for having me thank you very much
um so yeah i'm ben duncan i'm the
director of talent hub
we are sydney based a very small
salesforce
recruitment specialist company uh i'm
from from london originally but i've
been living in sydney for the last 10
years and uh
yeah no no immediate plans to move back
to the cold
i love that right so first question
interesting to hear this from you
so what was your biggest challenge in
2020
how did you overcome it and what did you
learn from it
um i i actually your point around how do
i overcome it i think that's still a
piece of work in progress like my
biggest challenge um
through 2020 and and beyond has has
always kind of been managing that
work-life balance piece
um so as i mentioned we're a small
business i'm i'm the only hands-on
recruiter in our business and my
colleague gemma manages all about
marketing and and builds our brand
ultimately
um and we've been really busy through
cobid we've been one of the fortunate um
companies that recruit an ecosystem that
has been pretty busy pretty vibrant
through covid
um so the biggest challenge for me has
actually been managing
um what what's going outside what's
going on outside of work and managing
the kind of stresses of
life in covid and and some kind of
personal challenges that we've been
going through
through a really busy time with work as
well and trying to be present in both
um that's that's been been a real
challenge because obviously i'm working
from home
um like i'm here kind of 24 hours a day
at the moment
and and being present with family life
and and work life is is a real challenge
um so i've tried to set kind of these
are the hours i work
um i have an off button um i kind of
have been trying not to read emails in
the evening
and and having actually really defined
uh working hours
and lunch breaks things like that but
but yeah it's definitely still a work in
progress because
um being a small business owner and
being very much on the tools
as you you know you know you get calls
at all different times in the day and um
and when something comes up it's
difficult to turn it away or look the
other way
yeah no thank you for sharing that so i
guess just real emphasis on the
importance of
trying to do your best to be present
with your family
and and work yeah really interesting so
on on this one then it'd be interesting
uh to hear this so what what working
from home tip could you share with other
recruiters that has had a sort of
massive impact on your productivity do
you think
um i i actually find that um yes working
from home is
obviously we're kind of all doing at the
moment but like have a dedicated area
that's the standard stuff but i like
getting out as well so if you can still
like have a have some time out of um out
of the
the office that you're in like i go and
to to
some some different spots around where i
live just to completely get a different
change of scenery
and i find like that the couple of hours
that i'm out of the house are my
most productive like i i actually go
there with you know if
you allow yourself a certain amount of
time to get a task done that's how long
it takes
um so by going to different locations
and saying
i'm going to be here on for an hour and
i'm going to knock this task out
like that that is always my most
productive time from when i've been
working out of an office environment
because yeah i can make things drag over
a long period of time if i'm at home
because
i've got other stuff going on or yeah
there's just other ways to drag
something out whereas
having a dedicated desk that isn't the
office space that you're in
day to um and and just going and really
focusing on getting some core tasks done
in that period of time has been really
productive for me
yeah nice interesting so what i know you
get a lot of inbound business but like
what has been the most effective way for
you to win business in the last 12
months
um yeah i think i think like having a
brand online has been been really really
important for me
um like it's something i've been
investing in for the last few years and
um and yeah it's just been a game
changer really like the amount of when i
pick up the phone to a customer
um if if it's a cold call they they
quite often have seen one of my posts
read a blog of ours
um but but yeah just really creating um
value in the market that means that
people want to come to me and understand
how we can help with their requirements
has kind of been the
the the key kind of business development
tool and that's just kind of constant
right so you're not having to to set
yourself a target making x amount of
calls per day because you've
got constant content that's going out
and stays online for long periods of
time so
um so yeah just just being visible
building a brand and um
and and having input to the market
that's not just we've got x amount of
jobs
yeah no yeah i'm not surprised about
that you've done that
really well and uh what what habit
or hobby did you start in 2020 that
you're going to continue in 2021
um carl i have it i think like this this
is completely non-work related but it's
yeah
so i uh i've started smashing my 10 000
steps
per day minimum but um like i go for a
really long walk before work
um i've got two dogs so like that's a
that's an opportunity just to completely
clear my head and not take my phone
um so i do a good hour then i go for a
walk for lunch and another walk in the
afternoon so
yeah like i'm kind of racking up 17 18
000 steps every day
um and and it's not so much about the
the fitness or the health aspect of that
but it's just good down time to be away
from my phone away from my screen
um trying not to think about like you
know interview processes i've got going
on
um and yeah it's been amazing like
before i'd sit on a train
not for very long we don't commute that
long in australia but i'd sit on a train
i'd be on my phone
um you know i'd be walking and talking
or like making phone calls
just absolutely having a clear head for
a few hours a day has been really really
beneficial
yeah i can definitely relate to that
that's awesome
what what do you think is better the
first coffee in the morning or the first
point post work on a friday
uh coffee 100 australian australian
coffee is the one
you're the first person to say that but
i'm i'm so the first i'm the first
coffee in the morning
and i'm still i was due to go to sydney
last year so i
cannot wait to experience that yeah
well if you are going to go to melbourne
too i'm not sure
but the the original plan was basically
to i had but to do a live podcast event
in sydney
obviously that count i had to cancel
that yeah yeah
i mean but yeah so i i can't wait to
experience australian coffee for sure
so next question is a bit more of a
scenario ben it's a slightly different
but basically i want to just sort of
hear how you would
approach it basically so there's a
particular business
on your target client list that you've
tried to communicate with and get in
with and start working with for a long
period of time over
a year but over that time they've had
touch points with you so maybe different
hiring managers have
sort of seen your content or engage with
it you may send a couple of emails
and through your candidate network you
manage to get one of the hiring managers
contact details
so you call that hiring manager they
pick up an answer and say hello who is
this
would just be really interesting to hear
sort of how you'd approach that
so you're the you're the hiring manager
yeah
cool um so i would uh
i firstly i'd i'd send an email first
like i'd send some sort of content so
there's a warmer call and
so when i call you i'd say hisham i've
just sent you an email um regarding some
of the the salesforce
um surveys that we've been running in
the last 12 months um i thought it would
be really prevalent for you right now
because i've heard that you're doing
a greenfield implementation of xyz
um i've made over 200 salesforce
placements in the last five years
and i'm really confident that i can add
value to your business um i've worked
with a few of the
the candidates you've got in the team at
the moment and i'd love to talk through
how we can add value over your
your next few requirements when's a good
time to come by and meet you to run
through how we can help
yeah solid it's that what's come out of
this which i think is really interesting
which you just did there is like it's
um leading with like giving rather than
taking
it is is the interesting point there i
think yeah like i think um
like my whole business um and ever since
i formed the business has been built on
value
um and that's like i've i i got talked
really
early on in my my recruitment career
that if you can add value on every
single call you make
then people remember you so like even if
someone doesn't really doesn't want to
talk to you even if you send them after
that like a
an interesting piece of information that
you've got
from the market or something that
relates to their skill set like
you're providing value and you're
different um so yeah everything we do is
around
providing value to people we work with
and then from there it just flows
organically into relationships and
ultimately business
yeah and i think i just think like if
the quicker
because it is sort of counterintuitive
isn't it like especially early on in
your recruitment career
you you're sort of given these
responsibilities or pressures to like
get them like
take basically it's like i need to do
this i need to get this out of that that
call blah
if you flip that blah its head and like
like you said on each call
you try and give more than you take it's
all going to help
everything yeah like i remember um
like in the early days when when i'd
make a phone call and then people would
say to you what did you get out of that
call
yeah exactly that that's the that it's
not what it's what did you get not um
you know how did you help that person or
how did you prove that you're the right
person for them to come to when they
need help
um and i think that that's really key
right it's um and that's why like i i
love
being a specialist because like i truly
feel i can advise and guide a customer
down a path or
or a candidate down the right careers
path um
and and that's why like i feel really
confident that i can add value on every
call
yeah love that right final question
is i just want you to sort of imagine
that i'm a recruiter who's
set goals for 2021 i'm hoping for a
better year
this year i've written them down i'm
feeling extremely motivated i i'm just
interested to sort of hear what advice
you'd sort of give me that you think
would give me the best possible chance
of achieving the goals that i've
set myself um i'm not a massive goal
setter i must be honest like i've never
been
i know that in the past when i've set
goals and i've written down a goal like
and and i've not i've not actually um
achieved that goal
it's because i never really understood
what that goal meant for me like if i
hit him what did it actually mean right
so
you know like buying a watch or what
what does that watch actually do for me
or
you know hitting a certain amount of
billings like what what do i
what how does my life change if i hit
that goal so i think like the the key
from for me
with um if i was to speak to someone
that is setting goals and looking to
achieve them it's like
but why like what does that goal mean
like why why have you set that goal and
how's that going to change your life and
and then go further than just having the
goal i have the vision around what life
looks like once that goal is achieved
because then it becomes real
and it's something you can strive
towards um because for me uh like
historically when i've had like goals of
hitting certain feelings and things like
that
it didn't motivate me enough because i
didn't know what would come with that
like i didn't focus on the life that
that would bring
yeah you need to go a bit deeper yeah
it's i had i had that realization
because
i'm not someone that's massively
motivated by money at all but actually
if you go i want to earn x and you
understand what that means
going to be able to take my partner away
on the holiday that we said that we
would do or whatever it's it's a
it's just yeah going a bit deeper and
going okay well if i do achieve that
this is what that will mean and that's
the part that
should hopefully get you more motivated
and give you more clarity on why
yes for sure and i think it's also
important not just to sit
don't just have goals because they're
what your your company want you to have
like you can have goals
i i think people fall into that trap i
have to have a goal this year but
if you have that kind of goal then it
doesn't mean anything like it has to be
something you truly actually want to
achieve
and you know why you want to achieve it
yeah i love that
ben that was 50 minutes of a mentor
thank you thank you for having me